is seemly deemed an act of Terror by the
people that the terror these weasly
words they're not weasly of course the
only one that's a weasel is you you
flipping coward you're a little weasel
if I was in Gaza if I was in an open air
prison if my family had been annihilated
by bombs from the sky if everybody I
knew had suffered the loss of a loved
one if I had no chance of any kind of
Freedom or democracy or standard of life
would I believe it was an act of Terror
or would I believe it's an act of
resistance against oppression a question
to all the bastards scums far right
prist Morgan you flipping scum dirt bags
a question to you
all imagine living for decades under an
open air prison where everything you do
is controlled from what you eat to what
you drink brothers and sisters please
donate as we have come together one um
to get the necessary Aid needed the
Palestine and Gaza keep them in your
duas but specifically brother and
sisters give from what you love
inshallah and love for your brothers and
sisters what you love for yourself
donate now inshallah whatever you can
and allow us to reach that Aid with with
one um to our brothers and sisters in
Palestine one day Palestine will be
free brothers and sisters and dear
friends Piers Morgan interviewed Andrew
Tate well it seemed more like Andrew
Tate invited and interviewed Piers
Morgan cuz he got absolutely annihilated
he got absolutely destroyed humiliated
intellectually and Subhan Allah it
showed that he's a double standard
hypocritical vile individual who you are
Piers Morgan that's what you are you are
a double standard hypocrite because your
boss at the top telling you what to say
because you will lose your damn job and
your damn lifestyle let's watch for
ourself I want to turn to the war
between Israel and Hamas in Gaza what is
your view of this War I think when you
call it a war you're doing a disservice
to the people are having their limbs
blown off by some of the most advanced
technical Weaponry on the planet it is a
genocide and is disgusting and it
doesn't matter which side of the
political Spectrum you fall on When You
observe a genocide in front of your very
eyes you should be disgusting which side
is waging genocide which side is w
waging
genocide can you imagine the
audacity this unbelievable unbelievable
let's carry on in the Israelis are
genociding the Palestinians and you know
it as well as everybody else well then
it seems like your bosses are not
allowing you to know it what do you
think of of what Hamas did in October
the 7th why are you starting the story
in the middle I just asked you about the
wi War I'm now asking I can't Prof I
cannot professionally answer that
question without talking about the
context that led up to October 7th well
nothing to my mind justifies what
happened October 7th nothing justifies
what happened before October the 7th
appear this exact point let's hold in
there for a second so he is just the
only focus that he has is October the
7th we have made it very clear our
position all of us as Muslims anybody
that kills innocent people for that
matter I don't care if it's Israel I
don't care if it's America I don't care
if it's UK I don't care if it's Isis I
don't care if it's Al-Qaeda I don't care
if it's Hamas I don't care if it's namas
I don't care it's whatever you want to
call it we condemn that in our religion
we are we are consistent with our
morality not like these individuals
because they dehumanize the Palestinians
the argument is the following if P
Morgan is claiming
that what October 7th is the highlight
of the issue and what they did was
terrible Etc and the logic is what is
because of them going and doing that
this Morgan is belittling what Israel is
doing to the Palestinians because of
what Haman on 7th October if using this
logic then that means that anyone
somebody can come and say well hold on a
second then what Hamas is doing in
Israel is justifiable because of what
Israel has been doing for the past 75
years stealing the land kicking them out
their houses killing so many people
arresting so many in the West Bank wam
is not even there persecuting them
massacring them committing a genocide in
Palestine so they can use the same
argument they can come and say well
because Israel did that therefore we're
doing is we're going to do that would
Pierce Morgan would you ever see Pierce
Morgan just justifying that no it
doesn't work both ways it's only if the
ones that are being killed are
Palestinians and Arabs and non civilized
individuals from the west then it is a
uh justifiable if it is them then it's
not a problem at all what utter
hypocrisy of a 15-year-old girl with no
legs begging to die yeah she was begging
to die saying I have no future because
my parents are gone or my legs are gone
no future no but you say that right you
talk about numbers and statistics and
you say a few people got caught you
don't think of gazin and you don't think
of as Muslims and Palestinians as
individual people oh yes I do no you
don't because you you if you did you be
happy with don't you dare say that about
me okay then don't don't you dare ever
question Andrew Tate for saying the
facts that he said you don't give a
bloody damn when was the last time you
condemned Israel as a terrorist State
when's the last time you condemned
Israel the IDF as a terrorist uh
terrorist soldiers never you coward
don't you dare question andrate you fool
you coward you're a p animous weasel who
cares about the only thing which is what
the Caucasian blond haad blue-eyed
individuals that's the only people that
you care about and he showed that that's
a hypocrisy and you got triggered but in
terms of what Hamas did on October the
7th do you accept that was an act of
terrorism it's an interesting question
because not really it isight because
you're the person who would have called
Nelson Mandela a terrorist while he was
still in jail and that is fact if he was
living at that time in South Africa he
would have called Nelson Nelson Mandela
a terrorist but now the Western World
the white man you know The White Man's
Burden who's come to save this us you
know uh primitive you know uh cavemen
you know they decide who's a terrorist
they decide who's a freedom fighter the
mujah in in in Afghanistan when America
used to fund the CIA used to fund bin
ladin and alqaeda to fight off the
Russians they were mujah Freedom
Fighters wo but afterward they become
what terrorists one person's terrorist
is another person's Freedom Fighter for
me to answer the question yes you would
have for for me to answer the question I
have to be very professional Piers for
me to sit on the outside in Romania with
no personal involvement in Israel
Palestine it's easy for me to say yes it
was an act of Terror however if I was in
Gaza if I was in an open air prison if
my family had been annihilated by bombs
from the sky if everybody I knew had
suffered the loss of a love one if I had
no chance of any kind of Freedom or
democracy or standard of life would I
believe it was an act of Terror or would
I believe it's an act of resistance
against oppression you have to be very
careful how you answer these question a
question to all the bastard scums far
right prist Piers Morgan you flipping
scum dirt bags a question to you all if
you was treated the way the Palestinians
were treated a simple question your
family was massacred you were being
persecuted everything is controled from
the water to the electricity to anything
that is coming in and out your land has
been stolen you have been put in a
specific corner like an island and
you've been bombed
continuously you son of a I would love
to say that word that's what you guys
are you are a son of a finish the
sentence inshah you scums what would you
do you guys the whole world will come
together against this against it yes
they would come together and they would
be like you know what this is Injustice
you are not even accepting the Injustice
that's been done you guys it's Israel
who has made Hamas they're the ones who
actually made their political party
Hamas not only that they are indirectly
recruiting for Hamas how in 20 in 2010 a
Pakistani born US citizen F shahad
arrested for attempting to do a
terrorist attack in Time Square his
attempt was to carry out a car bomb and
had it gone off it could have killed
hundreds of innocent people during his
trial shahad was asked why he wanted to
kill innocent civilian children shahad
responded and by the way he did was a
crime against Islam and it's terrorism
he said the following well the drones
hit well the drones that hit in
Afghanistan and Iraq they don't see
children they don't see anybody they
kill women children everybody they're
killing all Muslims Shad added I am part
of the answer to the US terrorizing the
Muslim nations and I'm avenging the
attacks because the Americans only care
about their people you guys are
committing and recruiting for Hamas by
blowing by sending these bombs that are
massacring committing a gen side you are
helping the cause of Hamas by carrying
on this vicious attack on the
Palestinians so my point is that you and
Hamas to go then return the land back to
them that you've stolen and let the Jews
the Christians and the Muslims and
everyone live in peace like they did
before you are stealing land if Israel
came to Florida and took Florida they'll
be up in arms they'll be up in arms and
not only that top US general have
appointed top top us generals have
pointed out that drone strikes makes us
L less safe than uh less less safe
rather than safer former head of joint
specialist operations Commander Stanley
misto has also pointed out that careless
use of drone drone strikes could result
in a suicide bomb in Central Park a
report carried out in 20 2014 by General
John abuz reported that civilian
casualties from drone strikes can affect
whole communities and become a potent
recruiting tool for terrorist
organizations so the point is what and
the list goes on General Michael Flynn
stated to in 2015 when you drop a bom
from a drone you are investing you're
going to cause more damage than good why
because these individuals would come and
use this opportunity former CIA
counterterrorism Chief Robert Grena has
admitted that drone strikes create more
enemies than they are removing them from
the battlefield so let's carry on is
seemly deemed an act of Terror by the
people that the terror is weasly words
they're not weasy of course the only one
that's a weasel is you you flipping
coward you are a little weasel you are a
weasel he is making damn good points and
you a Flippin weasel that cannot even
condemn Israel for the atrocities that
he's doing and you are justifying it you
coward scum the blood of the Palestinian
children and kids are on your hands the
Israelis think they're a terror group
and of course some of course the
Palestinians the Freedom Fighters stupid
that you're asking the question most of
the Civilized world thinks they're a
terror group Committed an act to
terrorism it's not difficult look he
goes most of the Civilized World well
let's look at this chart let's look at
this here brother and sisters yeah
nearly if you look at that measure that
looks like 70% or 65% of the population
of the Earth do not deem Hamas as a
terrorist organization so he is either
has two options P Morgan either number
one you are claiming that those Nations
who do not deem Hamas as a terrorist
organization are uncivilized barbarians
according to you if there's anyone
that's uncivilized barbarians it's you
and your Western world who has committed
M massacres killed millions of people in
h Hiroshima Nagasaki Iraq
Afghanistan Vietnam your list goes in
you have blood on your hands for the
past 100 years you cowards and now if
that's the case now you're calling them
uncivilized what they did was an act of
terrorism and I think that if Israel
continues to to conduct acts of
terrorism on the Palestinian people
they're going to do nothing but
strengthen the reaction going come I'm
going that's a different conversation
I'm about to have with you about
Israel's response but before I get there
one more time is Hamas a terror group
who committed an act of terrorism son of
you scum bastard when we when hijab asks
you if idv is a terrorist are they
terrorist is Israel a terrorist
organization estate terrorist State you
refuse to answer you scum you've been
asked hundreds of time you're talking
about asking Jeremy Corbin 15 times and
asking Andrew Tate over and over again
you coward have you condemned Israel
have you condemned the IDF no so shut
your mouth you flipping
weasel I think that when you lock people
in an open air prison you're going to
have to expect retaliation no because I
have to there's people who are firstly
first things I want to say per do you
don't mind me saying I think it's
spineless sure I do that's fine you
sound like Corbin well that if there's
anyone that's spineless it's you you
flipping coward you are a flip you boil
my blood the fact that you have the
audacity to question people about Hamas
when you yourself do not even condemn
Israel you
scum you scum are they a terror group
you're pedaling Asin nities because I'll
tell you why Pier let me answer the
question of course you are a simple
question that's like me ask I tell you
why I asked because the UK where you
were born prescribes Hamas as a terror
describe me as dangerous to children in
schools let me explain something to you
Piers if I would sit here and say is
stealing wrong and you'd say yes and I
go ah but what if the person stealing is
trying to feed their family and if they
don't their family are going to die is
it still wrong you're trying to take a
very nuanced and complicated argument
and reduce it down to one sentence which
is failure you're trying to equate
stealing with a mob of terrorists
breaking over a border going to Peaceful
is that what Israel did a minute a mob
of terrorist breaking over a border and
and killing people that going through a
border on October the 7th oh October the
7th ah there you go October the 7th oh
then me and Andrew T was thinking you're
talking about Israel for a second oh no
we're talking about October the 7th what
Israel does it's okay it's calm what
Hamas does is bad and by the way looking
at recent studies he's talking about all
this stuff yeah number one um killing of
uh innocent people yes he's talking
about the killing of babies false
decapitating people false rape false not
only that the the civilians that were
killed which were 12200 even har haret I
think that's what it's called Israeli
one of the newspapers yeah even Israel
themselves have said that they have a
specific protocol that they use in
Warfare which they would Target their
own citiz and they have accepted that
they were the ones that were that killed
all or majority or some part some of
their own civilians for that matter yes
so you are perpetuating lies you are
lying be just my point here is Justice
why is it when hamus done it is good
okay if they're a terrorist organization
so then is Israel's terrorist State no
you scum you're a hypocrite that's what
you are we just want consistency from
you not Hamas or this that for that
matter I mean that's it guys there's
nothing else to be said you can see the
utter hypocrisy and double stands of the
western media they do not give a flying
damn about the Palestinians they do not
care what Russia's doing bad Israel good
what else can be said Andrew Tay
absolutely annihilated him and destroyed
him Andrew Tay if you're watching this
video I love you for the sake of Allah
may Allah bless you you finished him off
and you didn't for for his flipping trap
this flipping scum double standard
hypocritical liar the blood of the
Palestinian children is also in your
hands you scum P Morgan till next
time may Allah bless you guys take care